Sebastián Piñera ya es presidente, bueno,
mejor dicho, vuelve a ser presidente porque,
como todos sabéis, este líder político
ya fue Presidente de Chile hace escasamente
dos legislaturas.. entre 2010 y 2014.
¡Hoy ha sido un gran día para Chile!
Ahora, tras conseguir una importante y abultada
victoria por casi 10 puntos, en las pasadas
elecciones presidenciales de 2017, el día
11 de Marzo, Sebastián Piñera fue investido
presidente.
Pues bien, amigos, en este video vamos a ver
que Chile hereda este presidente y también
cuales son los grandes retos que tiene por
delante.
Pero antes de nada conozcamos un poquito mejor
al nuevo presidente, veamos quién es Sebastián
Piñera.
¿QUIÉN ES SEBASTIÁN PIÑERA?
Amigos, lo primero que tenemos que tener claro
es que Sebastián Piñera, por muchos motivos,
no es un político más, no es un político
cualquiera.
Fijaos, hablamos de un personaje que, por
un lado es dueño de una de las mayores fortunas
de Chile.
Una fortuna, amigos, que la revista Forbes
estima, ni más ni menos, atentos, que en
2.700 millones de dólares.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Yo siempre me he revelado
contra aquellos que quieren apartar
del gobierno el espíritu emprendedor.
Me parece tan absurdo que prefieran
un gobierno lleno de operadores políticos
y vacío de emprendedores honestos;
que los primeros puedan postular a todo
y los segundos a nada.
Sebastián Piñera fue durante años una agresivo
hombre de negocios, hecho a sí mismo.
Y, es que, no os dejéis engañar por su sonrisa
profident … su historial nos demuestra que
durante mucho tiempo Piñera supo jugar al
límite y convertirse en un importante inversor
en sectores tan distintos como la construcción,
los supermercados, las líneas áreas o los
canales de televisión.
[Sí, ahora que lo pienso, es difícil dar
con un sector en el que Piñera no haya probado
suerte.]
Incluso, en 2006 decidió apostar por la industria
del fútbol y se hizo con el control de un
equipo… pero no de un equipo cualquiera,
sino del equipo más importante de Chile,
el Colo-Colo.
[Claro que muchos críticos le acusan de comprar
este equipo no como inversión, sino sobre
todo como trampolín político, a lo Silvio
Berlusconi]
Pero no penseis que las hazañas de Piñera
se quedan solo en terreno empresarial, para
nada.
(En el terreno político el actual Presidente
de Chile también ha dejado huella, sobre
todo cuando tenemos en cuenta que en el año
2010 se convirtió en el primer presidente
de un partido de derechas elegido democráticamente
ni más ni menos que desde 1958.
Sí, así es, Sebastián Piñera ha sido el
primer político de derechas en ganar unas
elecciones desde que se produjera la transición
democrática tras la etapa de Augusto Pinochet.
Y ahora, en 2018, vuelve a repetir.)
[En otras palabras, creo que bien podemos
decir que Sebastián Piñera es un tipo con
fortuna, ¿no os parece?]
Pues bien, el caso es que a pesar de tener
que enfrentarse con las consecuencias del
terrible terremoto que en 2010, apenas 2 semanas
antes de la investidura de Piñera, sacudió
el país, su primer gobierno tuvo unos resultados
relativamente buenos,
("Al menos la mitad del esfuerzo durante toda
la gestión fue dedicado a la reconstrucción
del país y en consecuencia se sacrificaron
muchas cosas que hubiéramos querido hacer",
Rodrigo Hinzpeter.
Ministro de Interior y Ministro de Defensa
en el primer gobierno de Sebastián Piñera)
Es verdad que no se produjo ningún gran cambio
revolucionario, pero en sus 4 años de gobierno,
el crecimiento económico superó el 5% anual,
se crearon más de 1 millón de empleos, los
salarios aumentaron y la pobreza se redujo
con fuerza.
("Tuvimos un muy buen gobierno, en el que
todos los indicadores sociales y económicos
mejoraron en Chile, pero tengo más experiencia
ahora, y la experiencia cuenta".
Sebastián Piñera.)
Y lo cierto amigos, es que en esta ocasión
toda esta experiencia puede ser muy, pero
que muy importante, ¿por qué?
Pues… porque el Chile de hoy es un bastante
diferente.
Atentos.
CHILE DE HOY
Os lo hemos contado aquí, en VisualPolitik
y desde luego no creo que sea algo que sorprenda
a nadie.Durante las últimas décadas, Chile
ha sido algo así como el Cristiano Ronaldo
de América Latina, el país que más crecía
y que más éxitos cosechaba.
Buena prueba de ello es la evolución que
ha tenido la clase media en este país que
se ha multiplicado prácticamente por 3 en
muy poco tiempo.
“La clase media en Chile creció desde el
23,7% al 64,3% de la población en 25 años”
Diario Exterior.
Sin embargo, amigos, tal y como vimos en un
pasado vídeo, cuyo enlace os dejo en la descripción,
en los últimos años, concretamente durante
la última legislatura de Michelle Bachelet
.
(En los
últimos años el crecimiento económico se
ha desplomado, la creación de empleo se ha
frenado, los salarios no crecen y la inversión
extranjera se ha desplomado.
En los últimos años lo único que ha crecido
en Chile han sido los empleados públicos,
los impuestos y la burocracia)
Sí, así es, practicamente todos los parámetros
económicos han tenido una evolución muy
negativa durante la última legislatura de
Michelle Bachelet.
Fijaos:
Por ejemplo, el crecimiento promedio apenas
ha sido del 1,8% anual, lo que implica que
esta legislatura haya sido la peor en términos
de crecimiento económico desde la transición
democrática.
De hecho, durante los últimos años, Chile
ha crecido menos que la economía mundial
y bastante menos que sus compañeros de la
Alianza del Pacífico, México, Perú y Colombia.
Y eso no es todo.
El déficit público ha pasado de invitado
a inquilino permanente, y claro eso tiene
consecuencias, la deuda pública, aunque aún
sigue siendo baja, ha alcanzado su mayor nivel
desde 1993.
("No es sostenible que la deuda fiscal se
doble cada cuatro años.
Ese es el camino del despeñadero" Felipe
Larraín, Ministro de Hacienda.)
Aunque lo peor con diferencia, ha sido la
caída de la inversión durante 4 años consecutivos.
Y, ojo, no ha sido solo la economía lo que
a ido mal, para nada.
Las tasas de delincuencia y criminalidad han
aumentado con fuerza.
En la región de la Araucanía, donde existe
un conflicto con los pueblos indígenas, los
mapuches, que reclaman más autonomía y reconocimiento,
los actos violentos se han disparado, han
crecido un 150%.
(E incluso en materia de salud la decisión
del gobierno de suspender el sistema de concesión
de hospitales ha hecho que el gobierno apenas
haya podido invertir poco más de la mitad
de las inversiones presupuestadas… haciendo
de las listas de espera y los problemas en
la calidad un mal crónico.)
Y... no nos engañemos, los más perjudicados
por todos estos resultados no son los más
ricos, sino las clases medias y sobre todo
la población más vulnerable, los más pobres.
[Vamos, que en otras palabras, amigos, creo
que podemos decir los chilenos no tienen motivos
para celebrar el último mandato de Michelle
Bachelet.
¡Menudos 4 años!]
(Tal vez la mejor forma de ver lo que está
ocurriendo en Chile es echar un vistazo al
índice de libertad económica, cuya correlación
con el nivel de riqueza y prosperidad de un
país es altísima.
Pues bien, durante el último mandato de Michelle
Bachelet Chile se ha desplomado, ha pasado
del puesto 7 al 20.)
[Y no, para los malpensados aquí no hablamos
de cambios metodológicos.]
En fin, este es el Chile al que se tiene que
enfrentar el nuevo presidente, Sebastián
Piñera.
Ahora la pregunta que tenemos que hacernos
es, ¿Cuáles deben ser las prioridades del
nuevo gobierno?
¿Qué podemos esperar?
Bien, veámoslo.
LOS GRANDES RETOS
Bueno, amigos, parece claro que con semejante
evolución y en un país que sin ser precisamente
barato 3 de 4 trabajadores ganan menos de
800 dólares al mes, la economía tiene que
ser la prioridad número 1.
Si la economía no va bien las estadísticas
sociales tampoco van a marchar bien.
Y esto es algo, que parece que el nuevo gobierno
tiene muy pero que muy claro.
(El nuevo presidente ha prometido que centrará
sus esfuerzos en duplicar el crecimiento económico,
crear cientos de empleos y sentar las bases
para que Chile se convierta como muy tarde
en 2025 en el primer país desarrollado de
América Latina.)
Pero, claro, como estoy seguro que estáis
pensando, vale, pero ¿Cómo lograrlo?
(“Espero que no se deje entusiasmar con
la idea de que solo con una reforma tributaria,
o sólo dando más seguridad sobre la dirección
de reformas como la laboral, será suficiente
para restablecer el crecimiento en Chile.
Va a necesitar una política agresiva para
estimular la diversificación.
Casi la mitad de las exportaciones del país
siguen siendo cobre”.
Ricardo Hausmann.)
Pues bien, amigos, para conseguir el objetivo
en el año 2025 el país tiene asumir 3 prioridades
muy claras:
Diversificar su economía; mejorar la productividad
y ajustar las cuentas públicas… y no, no
penseis que todo esto es un trabajo precisamente
fácil.
Para diversificar la economía, dejar de depender
tanto de las materias primas, especialmente
del cobre, e impulsar la productividad, el
Chile de Piñera va a necesitar unas cuantas
cosas:
primero promover la inversión, especialmente
la inversión extranjera.
Es decir, lograr atraer más empresas y capitales
extranjeros que apuesten por Chile para producir
y prestar servicios.
Algo para lo que vendría muy bien dar marcha
atrás a la pésima reforma tributaria de
Bachelet, que precisamente castigó la inversión
[¡Qué idea más mala!]
y también reducir la enorme burocracia, por
ejemplo, digitalizando todos los procesos.
Segundo… y este es un tema mucho más controvertido…
promover un programa de atracción de talento
extranjero, si promover la inmigración.
(Veréis, en Chile la población inmigrante
ha crecido mucho en los últimos años pero
aún sigue siendo muy baja, no llega al 3%
de la población.
Y amigos, a los chilenos les gusta compararse
con Australia o Nueva Zelanda, pues bien la
población inmigrante se acerca casi al 30%
del total. 10 veces más que en Chile.)
Sí, amigos, lo hemos contado aquí.
La mejor forma de hacerse con talento y promover
negocios y actividades diferentes es lograr
atraer personas con diferentes competencias
y capacidades del resto del mundo.
Hablaremos muy pronto, con más detalle de
todo esto, pero solo un dato:
En Silicon Valley, el gran centro de la innovación
mundial, por ejemplo, el 54% de los emprendedores
son extranjeros.
Y no, no se trata de hablar de barra libre,
sino de poner en marcha mecanismo que clarifiquen
e impulse la atracción de talento.
Al fin y al cabo, si las cosas se hacen bien,
Chile puede aspirar a convertirse en la gran
referencia para los negocios de toda América
Latina…. y eso implica necesariamente atraer
profesionales.
(Además, según las estadísticas disponibles
los inmigrantes tienen de media más estudios,
su participación laboral es mucho mayor y
ganan más dinero.)
Luego también hay que mejorar la relaciones
entre la Universidad y la empresa; combatir
las tasas de inseguridad; acabar con el déficit
público; mejorar las infraestructuras e incrementar
el ahorro son todas políticas que Chile necesita
para despegar.
Pues bien, si echamos un vistazo al programa
de Sebastián Piñera, veremos que las promesas
del presidente discurren en esta línea…
así que, en principio, a priori todo apunta
a que el cambio político en Chile va a ser
bueno para el país.
Claro que, como todos sabemos, solo el tiempo
podrá darnos una respuesta definitiva.
Pero, un momento, porque no todo será tan
sencillo.
(Debido a la reforma de la Ley Electoral que
impulsó Michelle Bachelet, la coalición
de Piñera no tiene mayoría en el congreso,
así que negociar y buscar acuerdos parlamentarios
será toda una prioridad para este nuevo equipo
de gobierno.)
En fin amigos, así están las cosas, pero
ahora turno para ti.
¿Qué opinión tienes del nuevo gobierno
de Sebastián Piñera?
¿Cómo crees que será su gobierno para Chile?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no ovides suscribirte a VisualPolitik
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.